[Applause]  [Applause]  hey  [Applause]  [Music]  uh  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  wow  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  somebody  [Music]  uh  [Music]  so  [Music]  uh  and the big question is how do you stop  kevin mobley the player of the year  expose the interior right there  heaven has been finishing with the left  hand and his left hand is as good as any  big man that i've ever seen  he's only 19 years old this mobley  blocked defensively  pinning it on the backboard  without any questions  [Music]  [Applause]  moved  [Music]  [Applause]  oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  of course  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  number one  [Applause]  [Music]  j15  the best two-way players  knocks down the three  jalen suggs knows all about all kinds of  spotlight  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  look at the explosiveness  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  wow  [Music]  [Music]  you